la vie de la commission pardon
excusez-moi merci et merci effectivement
nous allons aborder l'article 2 avec les
différents
je reprends nous allons aborder le
chapitre 2 avec les différents articles
notamment les minimum contributifs quand
même pour lequel nous serons
effectivement des propositions à faire
et puis également la prise en compte des
stages des tucs ça a été lachement
demandé et notamment la création de Lava
de la VPF il y a quand même une part de
solidarité qui est avançait dans ses
dispositifs alors certes c'est
insuffisant nous l'avons dit à Monsieur
le
monsieur le ministre nous pensons qu'il
y a des mesures de justice sociale qui
doivent être
ajoutés à ce texte pour faire prendre en
compte justement cet effort collectif
supplémentaire qui est demandé à tout le
monde et nous essayons d'ailleurs de
faire en sorte qu'il soit le mieux
réparti possible donc je vois pas bien
si vous voulez reprendre votre
dispositif et d'appeler ce chapitre
[Musique]
quelques mesures atténuant à peine les
effets délétères du présent projet de
loi je pense que il manque il manque un
peu de d'objectivité quand même et le
caractère même péjoratif à l'intitulé du
titre n'a pas été retenue par la
commission vous en doutez
monsieur le ministre
étonnement monsieur le Président cela
n'a pas été non plus par le gouvernement
pour les mêmes raisons que fait
l'évoquer par monsieur le rapporteur je
dirais simplement pour illustrer que
c'est par exemple dans ce type d'article
que nous pouvons créer de nouveaux
droits je pense en particulier dans la
création et l'harmonisation des
conditions pour l'accès à la pension de
réversion des orphelins et tout
particulièrement des orphelins
handicapés qui sont confrontés des
précarités plus importantes
merci
nous allons passer à l'article 10 je
suis saisi du demande de parole de
Madame Raymond poncemonge pour le groupe
geste
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais vous compter une histoire en
plusieurs actes avec plusieurs pour
protagoniste et de multiples
rebondissements acte 1 Monsieur Olivier
du sept ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion a déclaré que
40000 40000 futurs retraités
bénéficieront chaque année du minimum de
1200 euros prévu par cet article Jérôme
acte 2 Jérôme Guez socialiste en tant
que coprésident de la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de la
sécurité sociale s'est rendu à la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale une des
administrations ministérielles chargées
de préparer le texte afin d'obtenir
d'obtenir des éclaircissements acte 3 il
lui a été répondu que les services de
l'État ne sont pas à l'origine de
l'estimation portant sur les 40
000 futurs bénéficiaires des 1200 euros
je les comprends ils ont quand même une
expertise à faire respecter et ne savent
pas eux-mêmes d'où elles vient ainsi
aucune étude ou donnée chiffrée ne
prouve de façon que 40000 individus
recevront 1200 euros grâce à la réforme
mytokat en fait qu'autre seulement 10000
à 20000 nouveaux retraités attendrai les
1200 euros de pension 250000 parmi les
retraités actuels soit
1,5%. enfin selon la fourchette
d'estimation basse ou autre ce serait
respectivement 10% ou 20% qui serait
concernés par une revalorisation de 0 0
je dis bien à 100 € par mois cela
n'équère étonnant car très peu de
salariés font carrière complète à temps
plein au SMIC le groupe d'experts sur le
SMIC indique que seulement 6% de
salariés touchent 1,1 touchant 1,1 une
fois le SMIC font une carrière complète
c'est donc l'histoire monsieur le
ministre d'une imposture et d'un
mensonge
pour un sénateur d'appartenance à la
liste d'aucun groupe madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le président
mais Monsieur le Ministre votre
communication autour de la réforme des
retraites a été catastrophique c'est à
se demander s'il était vraiment
utile de missionner un cabinet de
conseils pour nous sortir un tel texte
les 1200 euros pour tous c'est ce que
vous promettiez avant qu'un travail
d'enquête soit effectué à ce sujet d'où
tant de cafouillage que ma collègue a
énoncé vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
l'inflation fait rage certes vous
semblait la sous-estimer ou éviter de la
prendre en considération mais il est là
et la majorité des Français la subissent
douloureusement au quotidien
Elisabeth borne déclarait que le
retraité avait le droit à une retraite
digne on se félicitant de la revalor
revalorisation de la pension retraite à
85% du SMIC c'est 1100 euros net
savez-vous à quoi il correspondent nous
prenons un exemple 600 euros de loyer
130 d'essence 70 de factures
d'électricité 200 de course sans de
frais annexes la France compte plus d'un
million de personnes de plus de 65 ans
vivant sous le seuil de la pauvreté
travailler toute sa vie pour qu'une fois
arrivé à l'âge de 64 ans un autre combat
commence celui de la survie parce que il
est impossible de vivre une telle
pension avec une telle pension faites
les comptes vous-même seriez-vous
capable de vivre ainsi en affaiblissant
encore plus le parlementarisme avec les
outils anti démocratiques que vous
employez pour bâillonner
l'opposition et aiguiser vous continuez
à aiguiser la colère du peuple qui selon
un dernier sondage est à 82% contre la
politique du gouvernement la droite
sénatoriale est juste votre complice
Monsieur Alain Dufour pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cette article 10 fait état effectivement
de
du patient minimum de 1200 euros
aujourd'hui des retraités les plus
modestes pourraient se satisfaire de
cette pension j'ai été amené à discuter
avec des organisations agricoles la FDSA
et gels agriculteurs mais aussi le
modèle pour la Confédération paysanne
qui ont indiqué dans les cadres de
diverses assemblées générales que cette
mesure allait dans le bon sens néanmoins
aujourd'hui la réalité est tout autre le
28 janvier dernier madame Schiappa a
indiqué que cette mesure de 1200 euros
constituait minimum constitué un seuil
le 6 février le ministre Bruno Le Maire
a indiqué également que les 1200 euros
étaient nécessaires or la réalité est
tout autre car dans le cadre de cette
réforme il faut savoir qu'il y a quatre
deux 4,2 millions 4,3 millions de
retraités qui en définitive sera en
dessous de ce seuil alors qu'aujourd'hui
il y en a 5 millions avec les textes
actuels donc en définitive ce cas
indiqué le ministre et les ministres
dans leur ses interventions depuis le
1er janvier ne correspondent pas à la
réalité il y aura certainement ou
seulement une augmentation de 33 euros
par mois donc pour atteindre les 1200
euros il faut toucher aujourd'hui 1100
euros si bien qu'il y a un quart des
retraités qui seront en deçà de ce
montant c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le ministre si cette réforme ne
peut vous dire et si les Français les
retraités ne peuvent percevoir au
minimum 1200 euros bien vous aurez des
contestations il y aura des
contestations des revendications
syndicales les paysans se révolteront et
je m'associe nos associés à cette
demande
[Applaudissements]
iez à une revalorisation significative
de la pension minimale afin que les
salariés ayant une carrière complète
bénéficie d'une pension de 1200 euros
brut soit 85% du SMIC vous êtes allé
monsieur le ministre avec vos collègues
du gouvernement jusqu'à prétendre que
tous les futurs retraités
bénéficieraient de cette avancée
historique selon Madame borne le 10
janvier aucun retraité ayant cotisé
toute sa vie ne touchera moins de 1200
euros par mois soit 100 euros par mois
de plus madame borne part du principe de
la carrière complète monsieur Véran lui
envoie le pas en évoquant une prévision
minimale de 1200 euros oubliant la
condition de la carrière complète
Monsieur le Maire persiste dans ce
dévoiement en février dernier la suite
on la connaît votre entêtement à ne pas
reconnaître le peu de portée de la
mesure proposée jusqu'à être obligé
d'avouer par courrier à Monsieur Guedj
que seuls 10 à 200 000 personnes seront
concernées par cette mesure
à 200 000 personnes sur le concernées
par cette mesure 20
000 j'y arrive ça y est cette tentative
de dissimulation a été vaine et la
manipulation est vite apparue pour ce
qu'elle l'est dans votre fameuse
interview donnée au Parisien si elle
vous avait qualifié de réformes de
gauche votre projet 3 jours avant de
féliciter la droite sénatoriale pour le
vote de l'article 7 vous persistez sur
vos chiffres qui ne sont pas exacts
monsieur le ministre vous devez à la
représentation nationale de nous
remettre les documents précis sur le
chiffrage dans cette réforme et vous le
savez il va y avoir des perdants et des
perdantes majoritairement puisque tout
et tous vont devoir travailler deux ans
de plus sans voir leur pension majorées
en réalité quant aux 1200 euros minimum
c'est une chimère cette réforme va à
l'encontre du principe de solidarité sur
lequel se fonde notre sécurité sociale
et notre système de retraite par
répartition
madame Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre lorsque vous avez
présenté ce projet de loi vous aviez
deux grandes annonces les retraites des
femmes et les petites retraites ce qui
va d'ailleurs souvent ensemble et
permettez-moi d'être un peu trivial en
vous disant que sur les deux sujets vous
avez tout faux vous aviez annoncé que
pour une carrière complète tous les
salariés payés au SMIC atteindraient une
retraite de 1200 euros mes collègues
viennent longuement de démontrer que ce
n'était pas vrai l'histoire des 40 000
des 20 milles tout cela a été démontré
et que dire des propos de Monsieur Véran
qui affirmait que deux millions de
retraités verraient leur retraite
augmentée avant d'affirmer que si les
grévistes étaient très nombreux la fin
du monde de tomberait
s'abattrait sur le pays alors Monsieur
le Ministre moi j'ai une question une
seule
est-ce du cynisme ou de l'inconscient
de l'inconscience parce que promettre à
des gens qui vivent avec 1100 euros par
mois ou bien moins qu'ils auront 1200
euros pour finalement qu'ils comprennent
au bout de quelques jours que ça ne sera
jamais vrai c'est certainement de
l'inconscience parce qu'il se
révolteront un moment et s'il ne se
révoltons pas dans la rue il se
révolteront d'une autre façon ou alors
est-ce du cynisme cette cette ce projet
de loi cette réforme il fallait
absolument la le vendre n'est-ce pas il
fallait vendre cette réforme une réforme
particulièrement injuste les Français
n'allaient pas tarder à se rendre compte
qu'elle était particulièrement injuste
alors il fallait l'enrober alors on a
pris on s'est servi d'alibi les femmes
alibi parfait comme d'habitude et les
gens les plus modestes de ce pays à qui
on a fait croire à des chimères alors
oui monsieur le ministre je vous pose la
question
inconscience cynisme
cynisme ou inconscience
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président cet article
me donne l'occasion de revenir sur ces
chiffres que j'ai déjà évoqué quel est
l'engagement du président de la
République garantir à assurer qui a
réalisé une carrière complète au niveau
du SMIC soit 42 années aujourd'hui 43
demain
intégralement au SMIC une pension
minimum à 85 % du SMIC c'est un
engagement qui avait été pris par la
nation en 2003 dans la réforme des
retraites de 2003 mais pour cet
engagement soit mise en oeuvre il
fallait en prévoir un mécanisme ça n'a
jamais été fait jusqu'à présent et il
fallait prévoir une indexation ce qui
n'avait pas été fait non plus c'est donc
cet objectif qui est poursuivi par le
Président de la République comment
est-ce que nous avons procédé comment
est-ce que nous vous procédons de
procéder pour les retraités actuels nous
proposons d'augmenter jusqu'à 100 euros
le minimum contributif majoré auquel
était ligible sont éligibles par de
mémoire les retraités actuels qui ont
une carrière pour laquelle ils ont
cotisé au moins 120 trimestres c'est à
dire 30 ans et ensuite cette
augmentation de leur minimum
contributifs majorée se rappro-ratisé en
fonction de
pour ces 17 millions de retraités la
revalorisation que nous proposons va
permettre en septembre 2023 si le texte
est voté d'augmenter la pension de 1
million 800 000 d'entre eux c'est un peu
plus de 10% mais un million 800000
retraités sur les 17 millions de
retraités actuels vont avoir une
revalorisation et pour la moitié d'entre
eux soit 900 000 cette revalorisation
sera entre 70 et 100 euros on peut me
dire tous les mots les plus durs qui
soient cynisme méchanceté volonté mais
j'ajoute un mot j'ajoute un mot
déconnexion des connexions mais je ne la
joue pas pour moi